so was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zur nächsten folge
minecraft nero heute wieder mit komme
hey was geht ab auf dem server letzte
folge musste ich ja leider ohne dich
machen aber heute sind wir wieder
vereint wir sind vereint und ich bin
wieder in dieser höhle hier wo ich
meinte dass ich weitermache das war die
hölle wurde damals auch schon relevanz
der ersten folge jaja ich gerade mal
dass ich irgendwie so ein grundstücken
oder sowas kläre ich hatte so eine idee
gehabt
ich habe ja einen wunderschönen youtube
namen kran kraft ich dachte mir wie wäre
es wenn ich mir ein haus bauen was ich
angreifen hänge das wäre richtig lustig
kram im projekt ich weiß ja nicht ob das
wird zum stadtbild passt aber wenn du
als bürgermeister das macht mir spaß
machen oder gefunden ein altertümlicher
kannten ja und ich brauche ab und schon
irgendwie so ein klong geräusch kasse ja
ja das ist der clown also ein riesiges
schwer
ich habe gehört der die recht gut damit
vor allem also wo hast du auch den wind
bekommt jedoch nicht ich bin ja okay
manchmal passiert einfach dass du so
spät 6 oder sowas bekommt und so kommt
das auch von einem clown
das ist einfach irgendwie dieses spiel
hat ja immer dieses element das die
götter irgendwas machen das geräusch
macht mich verrückt er muss sein es wird
immer lauter
bekommt er gehört ihr dann weg wird
direkter oder hast du jetzt rüstung
mittlerweile ich hab alten eisen
brustpanzer helm aber ich kann mir mehr
machen womit ich mache mir noch eine
schule also wirklich rüste dich aus dass
das nicht mehr passiert was letzte
letzte folge passiert
wobei ich natürlich jederzeit wieder
bereitwillig zu retten
der clown macht euch du ganz bisschen
nervös und seinem hupen die ganze zeit
ich weiß einfach nicht es sind halt
überall gang und ich weiß nicht wo er
ist
ich habe auch in andenken an dich habe
ich auch beste folge noch ein schild
platziert an seinem grab stand
dankeschön ja wir können es ja später
noch eine folge in der stadt treffen
genau den will ich dann noch lebe bzw
wenn du überhaupt schon fertig was mit
farben so leicht machen jetzt erstmal so
ein provisorisches baumhaus für ein
anfang
ich möchte ich halt auch nicht hier
anscheinend angst dass gleich dass ich
mich als mega schrecken kein problem ich
dachte ja vorletzte folge so also
plötzlich los gelegt hast oder schon
wieder so ein black rain jetzt diesen
wolf wieder moderat sogar 90 herzen
diesmal mache ich damit diese nicht so
schnell die teile das ist ganz gut
bekommt
und zwar hits nach zack und schon wieder
nur science loslassen für die waffen die
altenstädter schon was besseres ich habe
diesen sport noch das wollte ich mir
erstmal nicht machen
die haben hier die ganzen bäume um
vollständig abgebaut
unmöglich ist mach ich kümmere mich
schon mal im stadtbild ja alles klar
luxusprobleme nochmal diamanten finde du
hast seiner letzten folge schon
ordentlich welche gefunden ja ich habe
acht die erst gefunden
für den clown den ganz stolz was kann
man gegen clown machen ist das schnell
kann von ihm weglaufen nicht klar also
der ist jetzt nicht es gibt so mops die
so richtige sprinter sind
das ist der clown jetzt nicht aber so
richtig langsam ich da auch nicht
der wird immer lauter ich bin genau also
da muss irgendwo sein aber hier alter
ist dass leute ich glaube ich bin genau
bei ihm ja aber ich weiß nicht wo
ich mache mir jetzt übrigens leute
persönlich volk was das ist ich baue
jetzt erst mal mein allererstes
provisorisches baum häuschen oder so was
ich will später nicht unbedingt ein
baumhaus bahn
ich dachte du machst ein kran ja eben
erst mal im baumhaus weil ich das
irgendwie zum stadtbild passen direkt
hier irgendwie so rein rein scheiße ich
habe schon gesehen bei dem motto ach so
block in diversen farben da ist bestimmt
auch geldbörse mit dabei wie ich wollte
schon so ein so auf vermodert machen
also irgendwie mit grünen lehnen oder
und lianen dann sowas dass das rein
passt also ich hatte hatte nicht die
absicht das irgendwie dabei ich kann
absolut nicht bauen leute das tut mir
übrigens extrem leid aber es ist eine
tatsache
ganz gut aus schon auf keinen fall also
ich bin auch kein profi vor allem es
gibt auch niemand der so wirklich von
sich sagt dass er gut ist eigendorf und
aber es gibt schon die ein oder anderen
hier im projekt kann ich gut bahn also
wrote jetzt kann er super schön bauen
ich weiß wie das auf dem master bilder
gewinnt also keine ahnung da stellt er
stand ja aber wir machen einfach pvp
wenn jemand unsere wohnung beleidigt
dann richtig zur pizza auch leute also
jetzt nicht im echten leben machen aber
hier ist das schon eine gelungene
alternative auf jeden fall
ich würde am liebsten wirklich jetzt in
deiner nähe sein da es ist mir da fühle
ich mich viel sicherer als hier unten
links abberufen weil ich bin auch noch
so schlaue ich lauf grad den geräuschen
hinterher ich es macht mich verrückt ich
möchte wissen woher kommen diese
geräusche aus dem hinterherzulaufen
ich möchte einfach sicher sein wenn ich
dann in der hülle wenn ich weiterhin auf
last der entweder tot ist oder nicht
wir werden die denn lauter die geräusche
wie sind die manchmal richtig lauten
manchmal an werden die leistung okay ich
bin hier schon ganz in der nähe von dem
ich drücke die daumen also nicht sterben
komme auf keinen fall
ansonsten wieder schön die koordinaten
davor ausmachen okay sonst sonst golle
der dichtigkeit angegriffen
wenn man schwert hat ist ja eigentlich
ganz die zwei hyperaktiven schnell habe
ich vor überrascht das wäre ja ich habe
auch so genau ich habe auf den grafiken
geschrieben dass du von kollegah getötet
wurde vom boss schnell richtig dann
denkt alles okay dass ein heftiger box
gewesen würde aber das denken im kleinen
zwerg so ist klar
leute leute leute ich bin echt
schrecklich was bauen angeht
die firma schlecker als cool aussehen ja
man es vorsichtig angehen sondern kann
es nur nur du kannst du schlecht werden
nein es kann keine scheiße werden bis zu
ich hoffe die branche setze ich mir dann
her ich weiß nicht woher die kommen die
so weit dass auch weiterhin wahnsinnig
okay geht es runter so eigentlich muss
man ja immer muss ja ne eine türe haben
als eingang ja stimmt und die dafür auch
zerstört werden von anderen leuten aus
den städten ich nehme glaubst du wenn
ich ein pfeil türe nehmen weil ich habe
jetzt ein baumhaus sein ist auf jeden
fall klar
dann kann ich mich okay sieben minuten
aber jetzt gebraucht um mir diese
schreckliche baumhaus zu machen
erst mal noch ein schild und dann ist
keine bedenkt dass hätte keine ahnung
wer gebaut ist muss jeder wissen dass
ich derjenige winde so schlecht war
das finde ich aber gar nicht schlecht
weil dann vielleicht die unten in einer
höhle weniger monsters bord weil einer
oberfläche mehr sind bei dir sondern ehe
man da und darf man sich oben und
untereinander in der stadt was clown
nenne ich glaube nicht dass wird strafe
liebt das darf ja auch keiner also das
würde auch keiner machen aber vor allem
für so was brauchen wir auch absoluten
bürgermeistern auf jeden fall ging noch
mal eine treppe kennst das geräusch das
so klingt wie darth vader so irgendwie
so ein keuchen ist geräusch
es ist echt kein zum ist es also kein
normaler auf jeden fall ja ich habe das
aber auch schon gehört das geräusch und
ich habe es beschrieben wie ein
pädophiler der alm ins ohr
das ist für das vorspiel hier ja
wirklich so cool mit der todesstrafe man
muss ja echt anstrengend kann ich nicht
eigentlich so branche man muss halt
wirklich aufpassen dass man nicht stirbt
das sagt natürlich der der shriver
gestorben
sehr politische aussage ist finde ich
cool mit der todesstrafe werde keine
frau hatte in den mund legen und
irgendwas peaks herum und ich bin
oh gott oh gott ich will von irgendwem
commission wants angegriffen schnell
hinein hausbrunnen hat ottilie energy be
in rain willst wie dir deine energie
abgesaugt wird
mehr sprinten doch dort ist ging schon
noch aber irgendwie so ein cooler master
hat mich angegriffen
leute leute leute nicht jetzt die
schlucht runter einfach so
erst mal eine kiste machen und die
sachen sicher nicht dass hier alles
verliere so ein bett habe ich auch immer
noch nicht aber gut wir können sowieso
nicht schlafen nächstes jahr zu bild ich
hoffe jetzt einfach mal ich erwähne
einfach mal das wort diamanten
vielleicht finde ich jetzt mit den pink
dann kam mir hat ja geklappt beraten
ok ok ok ich muss mal klarkommen speech
zu eigentümlich für mich herum pieps
geräusche ich jetzt noch nicht das für
mich aber das nervt doch gestoppt
das ist dieses nächtliche piepsen das
macht das mappack irgendwie gerne müssen
wirklich ich habe leider kein holz dabei
als ärgert mich das wird mich wieder aus
der höhle raus treiben im endeffekt aber
man ist immer das gleiche
neustadt noch offen ist wieder die mine
ja die ist eigentlich auch jene ich
schaue da gleich mal aber zurück laufen
laufen das ist natürlich das wahre hat
ihren da er hatte doch schon hier unten
in der mine oder das schlucht von
diamanten gefunden oder in der schlucht
hatten wir direkt welche gesehen ja per
wissentlich noch nicht abgebaut
doch den gefallen können wir leider
nicht aber in zukunft werden ab sofort
für die stehen lassen kann
algier und mit dem ganzen projekt okay
nicht werke könig werde ich dies
vorschreiben
also ich werde ich definitiv nicht will
tut mir leid wenn ich das so sagen muss
ich werde die wahlen auch abschaffen
dann kannst du und dann lasse ich heute
ist das erinnert mich an einen erinnert
mich an einen gewissen junge ja freunde
projekt noch ich werde gleich mein
erstes eigenes blut opfern
das klingt krass oder so und da haben
wir den sex with the second life und
gaby wortmann diese sounds machen mich
verrückt die sind so eklig wie kommen da
jetzt echt solche komische geräusche
noch dazu nein das ist sowieso ein
ekliges piepsen immer ist glaube ich
auch echt doof anzuhören als zuschauer
da bleibe ich doch lieber juden immer
angenehm
komm ich werde erst mal mein eigenes
blut auf 1 321 ich kenne ihn ja niemand
ok zwei herzen jetzt lasse ich mal
lieber finden wir nichts riskieren so
schön diamanten und jetzt werde ich
einen tatort nicht nochmals kommt raus
aus eurem versteck
ich erstelle gerade einen blatt
matschiner luft ja also es gab doch bei
es gab doch dieses flachs mal aber ich
glaube das gibt es nicht in diesem
aspekt hoffe ich zumindest sehr 81 diese
negative energie ja genau wo dann
irgendwie diese bösen fee ist konnten
drauf bekommen wir ein riesig weil man
halt dieses flachs erzeugt hatten dann
kann man solche blitze und sonst
ich werde auf jeden fall nicht so ich
meinen zweiten liebe es fertigbringen
bringen hier bist du wirklich das ist
genau dieser ton
ich habe ja auch schon gesagt er hat in
1 erfolge so mikrowelle holzkohle kann
ich mir nicht machen
ich hoffe noch ein bisschen blut leute
ich höre auch wegen monster 80 talk es
ist ein zwei füße das ist ein ziemlich
böse aus
der relativ kleine aber hat nichts
gedroppt doch schaut ja das ist ganz
selten also manchmal ist es eine drop
schoss von von einem prozent belassen
das abgemagerte hier unten ist gerade
ein monster gespannt vor meiner nase
also ist wenn sie so dreist wenn leute
sich direkt vor meiner tür breit machen
die gegner dann ich glaube jetzt nicht
runter und hau dir mal eine rein macht
das macht auch wünsche ich will jetzt
ich hab auch keine diamanten von das
gibt's doch nicht
ich brauche unbedingt mit diamanten
spitze lassen so meine erstlinge dich
hier machen möchte portica das ding ist
übel stark wenn du mich blind es mir bei
mir ein hit landet kriegt das 15
hp dazu nein doch richtig heftig aber
ich hab's getötet kommt das ist für
meine monster einfach bei dem projekt
gibt es gibt so viele auch mit den
dimensionen kommt natürlich noch mal
unzählige hinzu und wollen das wird
heftig nummer darauf freue ich mich in
andere welten reisen ganz neue gebiete
entdecken weiß auch so viele
verschiedene gibt das ist ein echter
hammer das würde ich mega cool
also ich glaub ich glaube auch das
projekt das wird wird richtig richtig
geil
man muss sich halt erstmal sind willig
ausrüsten also diese diamanten suche und
so am anfang fand ich natürlich nicht
ganz so toll aber spannend ja aber du
brauchst du wolltest eigentlich nur für
deinen spitzhacken partie genau
vielleicht wie viele brauchst du dann
dafür 3 wenn du kein glück hast kann ich
dir vielleicht ein paar abdrücken oder
beziehungsweise dir oder wir gehen da
mal zusammen in die höhle in welchem
geschluckt als du wo ich jetzt bin ich
müde mich gleich mal nach oben mal wo
ich raus kommen da können wir vielleicht
über eine abkürzung direkt am rhein
das sind es wäre gut da mache ich das
mal konnte mich einfach direkt nach oben
so 2011e oh gott es dauert ja ewigkeiten
bis das ding endlich voll ist
ok ich muss muss richtig richtig viel
blut opfern damit ich meinen ersten blut
ob kriege
eine fledermaus creeper okay aber ein
krieger ist noch normal gibt schlimmeres
mal guckt sie einem in schächten um die
ecken presse steht ein krüper mal seine
these es gibt hier so ein sohn
übergriffen so ein wesen das tötet dich
sogar wenn du im creative mode bist fast
als das ist so richtig krank und das
weil man englisch werden können ja aber
das ist auch perfekt und ich hab eine
truhe gefunden übrigens ich habe da ein
adventure backpack gefunden was das ist
mega gleich ein paar war aber wie kann
ich das anziehen
in dem adventure black kannst du zum
beispiel ein schlafsack reintun dann
kannst du mit dem ding schlafen kann
wasser und lava
ja was ist es für 1 wie heißt das
adventure backpack clique manchmal
rechtsklick trafen klickst du unten
links auf diesen anzieht knopf dann hast
du night vision
ach das ist so cool ich habe nachts ich
immer wenn listing an heißt doch naja ne
du kannst einfach in der nacht sehen
halt eine night vision passion okay die
nacht ist vorbei und komm ich habe
meinen allerersten blatt ob der
ermöglicht mir jetzt dass ich meine blut
energie quasi transportierbar mache und
überall mitnehmen kann und überall
verfügbar habe und ich freue mich jetzt
mal nach oben und dann gucke ich mir das
gleich mal vielleicht bei der ansicht
bin ich etwas schon auf erdniveau ich
weiß ich hab das schon angehen
mein erstes haus wird echt na ja sehr
überschaubar aber nachrüsten nur nicht
über drei jahr wirklich so vielleicht
finden wir zusammen irgendwie auch noch
mal eine kuh aber wir sehen schon wieder
bei 17 minuten sehe ich gerade die zeit
vergeht ist es unglaublich ist wirklich
unglaublich ehrlich so zack weg damit
ok sondern macht mir noch mal ein
bisschen queenston aber ich habe gar
keine drei minuten
man muss wirklich sich in kleine feuer
machen bei dir dann muss nicht immer
klappen ich hatte mir vorgenommen
diamanten zu finden was habe ich
geschafft und keinen diamanten gefunden
aber auch durch zufall gefunden ja das
venture backpack ist richtig gut vor
allen dingen das von der fledermaus also
da kannst du dich glücklich schätzen
nicht nur annehmen wenn es dunkel ist
dass ich nicht unbedingt mehr jetzt
gerade
also ich brauche schon noch eine fackel
denn wenn du die nachtsicht drin hast
vielleicht ist es auch nur überirdisch
oder so dass man seine ich gleich mal ja
ich weiß alles leute ich würde mich ja
gerade genau wo ich bin schon an der
oberfläche kommt wasser
ich hoffe sie jetzt nicht ertrinke geht
darum ist das schaffe ich es auf jeden
fall herzlich eingeladen in meinen
baumhaus zu kommen beim house party so
dann vielleicht kriege ich noch ein live
nation single gemacht damit kann ich
nämlich überprüfen wie viel energie in
einem kreislauf okay ich will jetzt
einfach einer oberfläche kannten bis zur
arena statt ich bin in der stadt ja
kannst du mir sagen wie die koordinaten
sind
2206 ist die iks koordinate und dz -
1600 also 2200 - 1600 okay ich schreibe
ich auch noch mal das abgleichen kann so
schön ich habe nur ein bisschen voll
weit weg gewesen also nicht nicht
schlecht ich muss jetzt gerade ich bin
hier in einem mega ozean gibt eigentlich
auch böse wasser kreaturen bestimmt oder
doch hier gibt es sogar üblich ohne
haben uns nach apple minute ohne und ich
bin hier wirklich mitten im ozean und es
macht mich so traurig das schaffe ich
noch eine halbe minute irgendwie schnell
darüber freunde risiko dass sich fast
nicht stimmt leder brauchen wir ja acht
tatsächlich ein oder zwei eine nur auf
zwei stücke leder
schade schade besonders im wasser dann
glaube ich haben dann schon gefunden
glaube ich echt alte meister diese diese
türkisen in blöcke ja das ist leider
kein dann schon nicht aber ich schließe
hier mal mein haus hier sind auch hier
und da sind hits kühlen
juni treffen ich brauche 30 level um den
hunter dazu bezwingen da sind unten hand
hat drin in diesem wasser tempel echt ja
oh gott und greift er nicht an weil wenn
die dinger entweder wenn er steht juni
treffler und die teil der trotzdem mit
der herren kannst du nichts machen
ja ich bin schreibe hochgeschoben okay
so ich das mal genug und haben dann
wissen möchte was abgeben
so aber müssen aufhören
dann habe ich noch ein teenager
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
perfekt so richtig was geschafft heute
auf die kann ich noch meine energie
checken so sollen dieses mal rausgehen
zum nächsten mal macht's gut